all right hello this is a
instructional video on how a shockwave
works in pepper panic saga
they just changed things up a little bit
so i'm updating the video and um
it's actually a lot easier to understand
now
shock waves are made whenever you match
groups of four
or more peppers together
it can be just a regular
before pepper match like this one as you
see i'll move this pepper down and then
i get a shock wave that goes in
both directions and if you look closely
you'll see that all the all the peppers
in the path of the shock wave have grown
so
it's a um it's a unique feature to this
game
and um
it comes in handy in a lot of situations
here's another regular for peppermint
one and you can see all these peppers
grew
as well
now
the um
like i said that's the simplest one
there's also
five pepper matches
that you can make
for instance this one is in the shape of
canal we have a gap here
with uh
two
two pairs of green peppers and then we
have a fifth one we can bring together
in the corner that's gonna make an l
and if you watch
you'll see that it it actually grows
peppers in four directions
so that's um
that's the second kind and then
we could also make them in the shape of
a tea
which um i don't see one on the board
right now or we can make them in a five
pepper straight line match
in the old version or the only way the
game worked that these didn't make these
didn't actually create shock waves but
they do now so you have two pairs that
are vertical from each other it can be
horizontal or whatever and then you have
your fifth pepper here that you move
into the middle
and
it also
creates a multi-directional shock wave
so look real quick and see if i can make
up a t somewhere
here's most of it right here so let's
see
see if we can't move some peppers down
it doesn't look like we're going to get
it right there
if you've watched our video on how
peppers work you know that whenever you
get a pepper like this one stage five
you can um
it'll explode once it grows once more
so you know you can match that here no
explode or you can also shoot it with
shock waves and that'll grow it as well
so
let me see if i can't
maneuver this one into
a position where i can shoot it to show
you how that works
we have another one here too so let's
see
i have a blue one here we should be able
to shoot one of them
but yeah shock waves um
shockwaves are helpful
when you need to grow peppers fast
but they're also um
helpful in levels where you have statues
you have to get to
so
um they also damage statues later
whenever you're playing in the higher
levels they'll destroy um
petrified peppers and get them out of
your way you can also hit cages with
them
let's look at this this is a statue
board right here
and we'll
look at how
we can attack see these statues are off
the off the board completely so we can't
get to and through normal
um explosions
so we can just
make our shockwave matches
that gives it one hit
of destruction right there
so that's pretty much all there is to
shock waves like i said it they they
made them a little simpler today
um
they they it used to be different
shockwaves did different things but now
it's consistent across
um
all the different big matches that you
make basically the
the rule is
that all match all big matches all
matches above three now make shock waves
and all shockwaves
grow all peppers in their way